My name is Tang Guango, founder and CEO of BabyBus
Everyone calls me "Donald Duck"
I hope that this happy title will bring happiness to the hearts of all children
As a father
I used to watch my children playing and having fun
So I have to continue to find new ways to play
Our team consists of young parents and educational experts
Where we work together to try to reach the most educational application
Convenience and enjoyment for each child within different age groups
We hope that our bus (reference to part of the company name "bus") will have the same magical power
Which roams the world and offers surprises and happiness to every child
Just as Santa Claus does
Now BabyBus's "magic" is much stronger
Thanks to the strong support of the Google Play Store
My name is Luis
One of BabyBus's founding partners and application manager
Currently, 80% of our international users use Android
Starting in September 2015
All of our apps have joined our "Family Applying Applications"
So children and parents can easily find the app
According to their interests
Our downloads have increased by 367% over last year
Ice Cream & Smoothies is our most popular app on Google Play
It has been officially promoted on the Google Play homepage
During that week, it received more than 1.36 million downloads
The number of downloads of our other applications combined was more than 6.12 million times
My name is Ling Ying, Product Manager at BabyBus
We care a lot about our users around the world
We have created 12 versions in different languages ​​for most of our applications
Enabling them to meet the preferences of users at the local level
Thanks to the Google Apps translation service
Users can read content in their native language
The Admob network represents the basic way we use to invest applications
Providing more than 90% of total income coming from overseas markets
Collaboration with Google Play
The main factor for our success in overseas markets
We launched our first application on Google Play in 2012
Now, we have 103 applications on the market simultaneously
With total downloads exceeding 150 million times
Thanks to Google Play support
We believe that we will continue to deliver great educational products to children around the world